foreign  [Music]  from what your daddy passed down to you  but I wanted a child  the greatest gift of my life  [Music]  I'm visiting my mother tomorrow  hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to  say that I'm so so so excited to see you  tomorrow you're my angel and I love you  okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love  you  are you at the airport I'm on my way I  just  it's not safe is it  what do you think I should do  I'm sure you'll do the right thing  sweetheart  welcome back I hit you with my car  what I know  what what is this that's my little  assistant health monitor  feeling sad about going home both  [Music]  feel totally unreal I'm supposed to be  leaving I don't know if that's gonna  happen  [Music]  you will walk many miles  dozens will become hundreds  [Music]  hundreds will become thousands  your adventures will continue for years  and years this is a good home I know  [Music]  explosion it's not for me  do you want the truth now  [Music]  [Music]  foreign